you can literally make your own
sunscreen for way cheaper way easier
this is really dangerous as for about
why DIY sunscreen doesn't work the base
of the sunscreen is really important for
keeping the zinc oxide spread out and
protecting but I wanted to talk about
these oils with high SPF these are not
correct this study tested the SPs of a
bunch of oils on actual human skin and
got these results which are way lower
and remember this is the SPF you get
with a quarter teaspoon of oil on your
face oils are not designed to stay on
your skin in that thicker layer for long
so the real SPF would be even lower and
oil can actually make your skin more
transparent so UV gets through more
easily